we're here with jan de pomney
and it's been a tough tournament so far
finally a nice victory here against
maxine vashirograph perhaps a little
shaky at the beginning what's going on
uh
well it's surely not my best tournament
like
uh so i'm just basically struggling
every day and it's um
yeah maybe just
simply not enough energy but uh yeah and
this last game shouldn't you know
deceive
in that sense do you mean that you're
still not feeling in shape
um i mean if there is like an antonym to
the word of the [ __ ] that's that's my
case
well still a nice victory against maxine
tell us what happened exactly in today's
game it felt the opening was shaky but
then you took over
well i was lost after
seven moves
i could resign but then he didn't play
c4 and it was like
quite playable then yeah i think c5 is
not a move but i think there's 97 or
something case
is the move as far as i remember but
okay of course like
uh
uh
i wasn't like quite much to repeat any
lines so i also mixed up things badly
against te1 in there in the first game
so yeah i'm just
the internet has been wondering has the
announcement made you a bit upset is
that going through your mind
no i would say it affected but i don't
think it just affected that much so i
lost you know all my chess skills yeah i
mean immediately in one moment now i
guess it's just
yeah
sometimes i you know you go with the
flowy around is to rapidly tournaments
so so far flow is
against me but maybe this game would
change something well i hope so you
still have two more games here in the
rap bit well one more game sorry in the
rapid perhaps a strong finish we'll give
you good moods for the blitz
i hope so well y'all neptu here with a
victory with the black pieces against
mvl
thank you
alejandro thank you nepal